hello everyone
thank you for calling in today today i
will be presenting to you the new dna
encoded chemical library kit
this is a brand new product that has
been released by transcript
with you today my name is ruben azjar i
am the product manager for gene editing
and molecular biology products
at junscript and i'm actually very
excited to be presenting this product to
you
today so jumpscript a quick
overview of the company we have a global
footprint
we've been we've been in business for
approximately 20 years
and as you can see the progression we
started in new jersey and we have grown
fairly significantly throughout the
world and
as of last year we actually developed
the brand new kit that you are hearing
about today
so the dna encoded chemical library kit
or for short what we are calling it the
gender calculate
is based on the del technology which is
uh taking chemical compounds and tagging
them with dna barcodes to enable
high throughput screening so through
this
what you see on your on the right hand
side which is taking the chemical
compounds
linking them with dna barcodes that are
unique
it enables identification of these
specific chemical compounds
which enables very high throughput
parallel screening
so basically a single test tube would
would contain
millions and millions of compounds that
typically are
screened in spatial grids it is no
longer the case with this new
technology
so there was a nature review article
that i'm referencing up here on the
slide
that spoke about how much money this
this new technology
has saved for people that are working on
drug development
so in a conventional high throughput
screening for a million compounds
the typical compound costs about 100
dollars per compound uh which roughly
equates to
four million to two billion dollars so
this is how much
uh upfront uh money a drug
company would have to invest in to
to do this initial screening however
with the new dna encoded library
approximately the cost per compound is
reduced to less than two cents
so it typically costs approximately 150
dollars to create and screen such
compounds
uh however if you were to use an
off-the-shelf solution such as the gen
script kit
the hundred and fifty thousand dollars
are actually reduced even further
uh and um a lot of the labor a lot of
the time that
uh goes into developing this kit or and
then a lot of the expertise that you
have to build
um it's basically provided to you by
using this new kit
so i have a quick quote from one of the
people that was instrumental in
developing this technology
basically what he said is that it is
possible now
for academics and some of these smaller
laboratories to access compounds that
was a huge struggle for pharmaceutical
companies the giant drug companies
to develop for fair many many years
also what you see in front of you is the
progression of the technology
all the way from the 1990s where it was
originally developed
uh what you see is that it took
approximately
maybe 10 years or so before the dl
technology was really adopted but from
the early 2000s up until now
there's been a huge progression in the
technology there's been a lot of
adopters and people that have jumped on
board and expanded the technology
further
so almost all of the large drug
pharmaceuticals out there have actually
adopted this kit
and this technology and this is where
uh javascript uh uh enabled uh
this technology further by providing an
off-the-shelf kit
typically what impacts the del
technology are two main things one is
the chemical diversity of the actual
compound structures
and the second is the data analytics so
for the first one
uh typically what you see is there's a
specific library size that is very
suitable
very optimal when you're doing a screen
you'd
approximately a million compounds to a
billion
are very good anything more
typically becomes too challenging
because there's too much background
noise if there's
interactions between molecules that
aren't very strong
you end up losing them with the screen
because there's just too much
compounds there's too much happening in
one tube
the other component which is very
important is the structural diversity of
these chemical compounds
so what you want to see is linear and
spherical
core structures which is what the gender
calculate is based off of
and the last point that i have up there
is the coverage of drug-like candidates
so what you want to see in a chemical
library
is is good coverage of drug-like
candidates which i will speak about in a
minute
the other aspect of the impacting
factors
is the data analytics so whenever you're
looking at a sequence
of a chemical molecule that was
identified as a hit
you want to have the expertise to be
able to characterize
the molecules that were identified as a
hit
so the wonderful part about the gender
calculate is that the analytical aspect
is actually
provided to the scientists free of
charge
so what you what you see on the right
hand side the data analytics this is
something that javascript will be
providing free of charge
so once you have a sequence that was
identified as a hit
we will be able to characterize those
hits based on the enrichment value
not based on just the sequencing this
means that we will be able our team will
be able to identify
any sequencing bias that would be
generated
by conventional high throughput
sequencing the other data analytics
aspect that is also very important is
not to simply look at the enrichment
point
um if you were to do that on a on an
expertise level
um you would be introducing or you
wouldn't be identifying the false
positives
which is very very important because you
want to reduce the amount of hits that
aren't necessarily a true hit this will
reduce
the cost down the line so the way that
we do it is actually by looking at the
structural activity relationship
and i do have a case study that i will
talk about a little bit later on
but this is very very um important when
you're doing
uh data analytics of the identified hits
in the chemical screening
so what the gen script kit is providing
you with is that it is completely
accessible
off the shelf what you're going to get
is a single tube
that contains all of the dna encoded
chemical libraries
um the uh the kit is actually very
affordable
and it's ready to use so you once you
obtain that kit you can go ahead and
conduct your screening right away
the library consists of a collection of
18 sub
libraries and i can talk about that in a
minute as well
and a total of 400 million diverse
molecules
and the last component of what you're
what i have up there
is that the hit analysis is going to be
be performed
for you and provided to you by an
industry leader
so what you have in front of you is the
protocol of how
a screening is conducted using the
gendikal
so the first step is to take the protein
of interest or your target of interest
and then bulbalize it on a magnetic beat
so um you are able to pick any kind of
affinity um
a beat that you are interested in um we
won't limit you to that
as long as it's a good um a good
binding molecule and it's going to hold
your protein of interest that way you
can conduct your screening
effectively once you have your protein
of interest
immobilized on this magnetic bead you
are going to add
your gen decal library and incubate it
with your immobilized protein
this will enable the the um the um
the actual screening and for the hit
compounds to bind to your model to your
uh protein of interest
so you need to allow for that in a in a
specific environment that way you get
that
bond protein once your protein is banned
which is what you see um in between
number three and number four
um you're gonna go ahead and wash away
any unbound compounds the gentical
compounds that did not bind
so whatever is bound is your hit
compound and you're gonna go ahead
and amplify the dna barcode which is
tagging your chemical
compound that has bound to your protein
of interest
and go through high throughput screening
once you have conducted your high
throughput screening
you're going to provide javascript with
the data
and the scientist that has
the expertise that i mentioned earlier
is going to
prepare a report for you and will be
provided to you
one thing to note is that you will not
be sharing your protein of interest with
us
so everything that is on what you see up
here is actually proprietary to you
we will not get visibility to that what
we will get visibility to
is the dna barcode tag sequence
which will enable us to provide you with
the report that i mentioned
so what you have in front of you here is
actually the 18 chemical sub libraries
that the gen decal
is built on uh and you see that there's
a breakdown of the library size
that's for the next three slides
one thing to know as well is there's a
dna control
um which is actually very important
because it will also enable us to do
our own analysis to make sure that you
got a good
hit so the chemical library structures
that i mentioned um
in the four slides before um they're
actually
broken down into a few different uh
structures
you have your linear your scaffold and
your micro cycle
and what you're going to see with the
jendika library kit is that
you have a little bit of linear you have
a little bit of micro cycle
but the majority of the kit is based off
of the scaffold structures
which is actually what you want so
basically the molecules are developed in
such a manner
or built in such a manner that they are
overlaid with one another
and this is what gives the kit the
diversity
and the drug-like molecule structures
that you want to see
in the gender calculator
so one of our team members actually
developed a quick analysis
not quick but they developed an analysis
to analyze the chemical properties and
the physical properties of the molecules
and what we were able to identify is
that
the decal kit by taking a thousand
molecules
from this kit um is
actually fits into the lipsky's rule of
five
so the case rule of five is actually um
um uh it's it's basically uh based off
of the
uh the orally um and um um
drug viable molecules uh in the industry
um basically the rule uh
talks about how the absorption and
permeation of
specific drug molecules fit into this
rule
so the majority of them um these drug
candidates that are
considered good for oral availability
is is based off of these physical
properties that you see up here
so what you see up here is that the
majority of the
javascript molecules actually fit within
this graph
another analysis that was conducted by
our team is that we took
the 18 gendika libraries uh
and we overlaid them with the drug bank
released molecules and what you see
is that there was actually an overlap of
over 98
so um it's actually uh basically what
you want to see you want to be screening
your protein of interest or your target
of interest
against drug-like molecules that would
mimic
these structures so over 80
overlap is exactly what you want to see
where there's a little bit of
uniqueness and the majority of the kit
is actually
very much in line with the drop bank
uh we were also able to conduct another
case study
the case study that you see up here
shows
specific protein that was identified
as a hit um so i'm going to try to zoom
in here
so there's the gen decal kit number two
gen decal kit number four and then the
kit number three
and kit number five that i have showing
as a case study
so the hits that you see down here which
is which is the spatial grid
that you see in front of you um showed
uh basically um this cubic mac
it indicates that there is an enrichment
service
of these molecules that are sharing
these building blocks
so these molecules that were identified
as a heck
are actually what what bound to your
compound of interest
and what you see on your left hand side
is the hits that were identified by the
gendikal
so this is actually uh oops
this is actually um very much in line
with a um hit that was identified by jsk
and i cited their article down here
which is which
was um very similar in structure to the
um the hit that was identified by the
gentico
so it was definitely an indication of
the success of the kit
so um basically what i mentioned earlier
with regarding
to the structural um similarities in the
building blocks
um that we were able to parse out using
the
um the analytics that our team has
developed and has has
the ability to identify
this is what you see up here you do see
some
molecules that are actually uh
were considered a hit if you were to
just to look at the sequence data
however by looking at the um at the
cubic map
you see that there's really no
clustering
or cramping of these building blocks or
where there's a spatial grid that you're
showing that these molecules are
clustered together
this is actually an indication of a
false positive
this means that even though these these
molecules that are
shown as a head um by looking at the
specific
sequence data however by laying it out
on a spatial grid and showing the
side-by-side analysis
um for the building blocks and the and
the different structures
similarities of the hits you see that
this is actually not a true hit
so by by using our expertise and our
ability to do this analysis a little bit
deeper
we we can parse that the pro the hits
that aren't necessarily
uh what you want to see also here's
another example of a false positive hit
or a potential hit that might be
investigated a little bit further
which is this molecule that also showed
a high enrichment
value uh however the compounds
adjacent to it um showed a slightly
lower enrichment value
and they could potentially be something
that's a hit
but they don't look very promising so we
can potentially flag them and provide
them in the report however they're not
very
strong hits and with that i'd like to
open it up to
any questions that the attendees have
i i'd love to hear from you i left my
contact information here
if you have any questions pertaining to
the kit the one comment i want to leave
you with
is that even though the kit there's been
a lot of development throughout the
industry by different pharmaceutical
companies
so if you are a pharmaceutical person
that is working with
dna encoded chemical library and you
have your own kit that you've developed
in-house
what i want to leave you with is that
this kit would be complementary the
agenda calculate would be complementary
to what you're using
because every time that you develop such
a kit
you're using different building blocks
you're doing you're using different
chemical compounds and you're
structuring them and developing them in
a different manner
so this kit would be complementary to
what you
would be using so i highly encourage you
to test it to try it
we are actually looking for
collaborators as i mentioned earlier in
the presentation
this is a brand new product for us so
we'd love to grow our business
and collaborate with people that are
interested in working with us
um so with that i'd love to hear from
you contact me feel free to do that
and i wish you a good day